if you ever want to feel what it's like
to to be like three again make your
thumb wrestle your pinky your pinky's
like [ __ ]
you have no power in your pinky pinky's
so weak
that's what it's like to be like a
three-year-old straining against your
older brother
get off me [ __ ] you got a pinky
that's right is that what a [ __ ]
little digit
what does that thing get used for don't
eat like
i hurt my pinky doing that wrestling
with my thumb like legitimately it hurts
now
so weak i but i do so much with my hands
i'm sure so many chin ups
there's some reason for it so many
kettlebell grips and it's mostly these
other fingers
even when you draw back a bow might
release it doesn't even have a pinky
thing
i draw back with these fingers this
[ __ ] ass just hangs around for the
right you're so mean to your pinky
why do you do that i love my pinkies
yeah i love them it's weird how weak it
is compared to all the other digits here
and they named it a pinky
it's it is a a very like yeah that will
[ __ ] you up with this finger
this finger right here is strong as [ __ ]
this finger gets a hold of [ __ ]
this is a strong finger this is a
[ __ ] finger that's not hurting
anybody
we are all in the same hand listen
everyone belongs on the hand like we
imagine the pinky
if you were as strong physically as your
small toe
wow that's great that's life just
everything can [ __ ] you up every pebble
is murderous
every jumping off stairs the wrong way
you stub your toe you want to die
your little baby toe has zero power grab
your little baby toe
and like wrestle with it real quick it
has nothing it's a mess it's a baby
yeah babies are stronger than your baby
toe yeah well look it's a bitch-ass
little limb
yeah that would that's the funny thing
about the human
sentient projection into time it's like
we're probably like the
little toe of the universe